tag eins der teil mobilisierung der
russischen armee die gestern ausgerufen
wurde von diktator putin und diese teil
mobilisierungs ankündigung hat ganz
unterschiedliche reaktionen
hervorgerufen wir schauen uns erst
einmal bilder von gestern abend an aus
den großen städten von westrussland hier
erst mal fotos oder bilder aus sankt
petersburg dort sind etwa 2000 bis 3000
menschen vor allem junge menschen auf
die straße gegangen haben demonstriert
haben unter anderem gerufen nein zum
krieg und putin an die front und hier
haben wir aufnahmen aus moskau wo man
sieht wie diese menschen abtransportiert
werden sie wurden nahezu alle gefangen
genommen wir haben 1400 festnahmen bis
heute morgen gesehen tatsächlich wie die
behörden wie die polizei boutin
schlägertruppen hier von amon jeden
einzelnen demonstranten abschleppen dass
also die reaktionen gestern abend in den
westlichen städten jain wir sehen dass
hier auch fran spray sehen wir dahinter
in den städten also wenn man so müsse
europa angekommen ist doch russland ist
viel größer das wissen wir und wir sehen
uns das ganze mal an diese aufnahmen
sind von heute morgen haben uns erreicht
und das sind die großen die jetzt an die
front müssen und diese aufnahmen sind
4000 kilometer östlich von moskau
entstanden in der region trans bei
partien in der nähe der mongolei und in
der nähe von china von dort haben wir
heute morgen diese aufnahmen bekommen ja
junger menschen die jetzt an die front
müssen völlig unbedarft wie man sieht
die also offenbar keine ahnung haben was
da auf sie zukommt die auch vielleicht
weniger jahr weniger an den westlichen
medien auch teilhaben können wie die
menschen in sankt petersburg oder moskau
und hier haben wir bilder aus
tschetschenien auch dort heute morgen
massen an jungen männern die einberufen
werden die also sich jetzt aufmachen auf
dem in den krieg in die ukraine das also
kadyrov es reicht wenn man so möchte
auch aus yakuza im fernen osten des
landes haben wir heute morgen zu
aufnahmen gekriegt überall dort ja wo
man muss ganz ehrlich sagen wo eben die
russen leben von den podien auch nicht
viel hält die sind eben ganz weit weg
das sind menschen die schon seit anfang
des krieges geschickt werden in die
ukraine ich denke man kann mit recht
sagen dass putin diese menschen als
entbehrlich empfindet diese müssen heute
morgen in den krieg und müssen jetzt für
russland kämpfen in der ukraine wir
wollen auch gucken weitere aufnahmen uns
an aus dem westen russlands dort gibt es
vorboten von dem was uns jetzt bedrohen
könnte wenn putin nämlich nochmals
eskaliert nämlich dieser lkw hier wurde
gefilmt in krasnodar sie sehen ein
russischer armee lkw und am kennzeichen
und was wir da hinten dran sind sind
unfassbar gelagerte bei jay s p500
bomben das sind halb tonnen bomben
freifall bomben der russischen armee die
auch schon seit 40 jahren eingesetzt
werden und wir sehen uns das einfach mal
an und erfährt hier über die autobahn
und liefert diese bomben offenbar zu
einer militärbasis und wir haben
aufnahmen aus dem april die uns zeigen
was denn passiert wenn so eine bombe
einschlägt und hier glücklicherweise
kein haus trifft sondern in einem
modrigen oder jahr in einem schlammigen
boden trifft wir sehen hier einen
menschen der in diesen bombenkrater
hineingeht und es ist kaum zu glauben
dass dann wirklich 15 meter bombenkrater
die hierdurch eine fab 500 heraus ja
sozusagen ausgelöst wurden jetzt sehen
wir wieder unten winkt das passiert wenn
so eine bombe einschlägt russland hat
sich am anfang des krieges benutzt dann
aber nicht mehr aufgrund der immer
stärker werdenden ukrainischen
flugabwehr jetzt könnte es sein wenn wir
zumindest diesen bildern glauben den
aktuellen dass putin erneut darüber
nachdenkt große piloten zu opfern und
wieder eben bomber mit freifall bomben
mit um ihr dummen bomben wenn man so
möchte in die ukraine zu schicken zu
guter letzt wollen wir uns ein weiteres
bild aus der ukraine ansehen und zwar
111 wie video das ist schon in sich hat
wie ich finde wir haben in den letzten
monaten immer wieder von diesen
westlichen artilleriegeschützen
gesprochen der m 77 team aus
großbritannien der haubitze 2000 aber
auch diese monster des kalten krieges
würde ich mal sagen die gier cent es die
wir hier sehen sind weiterhin wichtig in
den arsenalen der ukraine das ist also
152 mm geschützt wir sehen jetzt hier
wies beladen wird wieder jemand die
treibladung hinein packt das kann etwa
30 kilometer weit schießen und wir sehen
auch weiterhin wichtig diese alten
sowjetischen geschütze aus den 70er aus
den 80er jahren für die ukraine sind das
wird jetzt hier betätigt und wir sehen
ist wie es feiert und die ukraine hat 25
stück davor in russland über 1000 und
wir sehen aber weiterhin auch diese
alten sowjetischen geschützt sind neben
den vielen westlichen
land kommen wichtig für die ukraine um
diesen krieg voranzutreiben und am ende
hoffentlich auch zu gewinnen
[Musik]